wen hätten sie nicht gerne als nachbarn
donald trump vielleicht so geht es
zumindest einigen bewohnern von malaga
der residenz in florida und durch einen
schlauen gesetzes kniff könnten sie den
ex-präsidenten vielleicht bald als
nachbarn los sein denn es geht ums
steuer zahlen und das macht donald trump
bekanntlich ja nicht so gern
das neue leben von donald trump als
ex-präsident beginnt mit neuen
kontroversen trump wohnt seit dem abflug
aus washington in seinem luxus resort
mara lago in palm beach in florida 118
räume 5810 quadratmeter wohnfläche pool
tropengarten 180 millionen dollar wert
doch privatsphäre wird donald trump hier
nicht haben
mara s trägt sich über 72.000
quadratmeter es ist ein riesiges gebiet
aber donald trump heiter sich mit 500
mitgliedern und ihren gästen und john
ist hier auch nicht überall ein gern
gesehener gast
es gibt klagen von nachbarn und sogar
eine mögliche debatte im gemeinderat ob
er dort etwa illegal lebt um seine neue
adresse und um seinen weiteren
aufenthalt dort ist sogar ein rechts
krieg ausgebrochen
es haben sich einige nachbarn beschwert
einige sogar mit gerichtsklagen über den
aufenthalt von donald trump im
mittelpunkt dieses streits steht ein
vertrag den der damalige immobilien
mogul abgeschlossen hat mit der
stadtbahn beach wo er sich verpflichtet
hat mar lago nicht als residenz sondern
als privaten club zu führen und die
auflagen waren dass er hier nur 21 tage
pro jahr wohnen haben seit mittwoch 11
uhr 32 ortszeit also genau eine woche
nach seinem eintreffen nach dem exit aus
dem weißen haus hält sich der ehemals
mächtigste mann der welt praktisch
illegal in lago auf und erstmal lago
zugeschaltet ist uns jetzt herbert
bauernebel ja hallo herbert das ist
jetzt nicht mehr nur ein harmloser
streit unter reichen nachbarn sondern
das spitzt sich ja auch ganz schön zu
wie kam es denn dazu
zum einen gibt es natürlich diesen
kleinkrieg der genervten nachbarn gegen
donald trump der eben hier hinter mir in
malaga dieser prächtigen anlage lebt
daher gibt es vorwürfe einer nachbarin
die genau daneben wohnt dass hier der
ultraschall zaun zu gehirnschäden führen
würde dann ist wieder mal ein fahnenmast
zu hoch dann gibt es eine debatte um
einen hubschrauberlandeplatz oder einen
geplanten bootssteg das ist ein hit hier
in palm beach ein kleinkrieg wenn man so
möchte aber wichtiger natürlich ist die
der showdown eigentlich um das
aufenthaltsrecht von donald trump in
seinem eigenen club trainer wie gesagt
im jahr 1993 gab es einen deal mit der
stadtverwaltung der beschränkt den
aufenthalt von donald trump in malaga
und was man hier gehört hat in palm
beach ist dass der anwalt der staat sich
darum kümmern dass das jetzt geprüft
werden soll denn wie gesagt da wohnt
jetzt schon länger als sieben tage der
maximalen verweilzeit laut dem vertrag
und man werde sehen auch wie der
stadtrat entscheidet da gibt es eine
sitzung geben an den anfang des nächsten
monats allerdings es gibt auch stimmen
hier in palm beach die sagen das alles
eigentlich rechtens wäre es gibt ja eine
sehr versierte lokale journalistin die
den vertrag mehrmals studiert hat und
die sagt das ist eigentlich hier keinen
expliziten passus gibt der donald trump
verbietet hier in seiner eigenen anlage
zu leben also der kampf ums wohnen bei
donald trump jetzt weiß ich der ist da
ganz abgeschottet in marl lago hast du
ihn trotzdem hast du mail an ja
irgendwie sehen können in den
vergangenen stunden tagen weißt du was
er so treibt im moment
ja das ist eigentlich fast ein mysterium
einer donald trump habe natürlich auch
seinen twitter-account nicht mehr man
weiß also sehr wenig was er eigentlich
tot klar ist dass er ab und warnt zum
golfen fährt dann bewegt sich hier die
wagenkolonne über eine brücke hinüber zu
seinem golfplatz auch das nervt die
anwohner mehrmals denn hier wird alles
abgesperrt als eine ganze stunde die
straße dicht über melania hat man auch
noch nicht sehr viel gehört allerdings
klar ist dass donald trump eine weitere
wichtige rolle spricht spielt innerhalb
der republikaner partei hier gab es
gestern etwa den besuch des top
republikaner der kevin mccarthy aus dem
repräsentantenhaus der wo dort hier
praktisch hof gehalten hat denn wie
viele auch hier in palm beach sagen ist
das nach wie vor transport id menschen
stehen hinter ihm und auch viele
parteifunktionäre man darf nicht
vergessen donald trump ist insgesamt
sehr populär in florida hat auch hier
die wahl gewonnen hier in palm beach ist
die lage etwa 50 50 abnehmer abneigung
und zustimmung zu donald trump aber klar
ist dass ist nach wie vor donald trumps
partei sein einfluss ist groß und man
wird jetzt auch sehen in den nächsten
jahren besonders bei den midterm
election im nächsten jahr seine
kandidaten sein einfluss den
republikanern als siege bescheren kann
und natürlich es wird weiterhin
spekuliert ob er selbst noch einmal
antreten möchte im jahr 2024 praktisch
zum rückspiel gegen joe biden bei der
nächsten präsidentschaftswahl
wir sind bild und wir liefern dir deine
news auf youtube zum nächsten video
kommst du hier
und vergesst bitte nicht unseren kanal
zu abonnieren